there are six starting classes in tiny
tina's wonderlands and whether you want
to be a hammer swinging fire god a
badass do wielding gun wizard or you
just can't decide what you want to be we
have you covered so hit that subscribe
button give us the old thumbs up and
let's get you going on which class is
right for you
from the previews and trailers the spore
warden looked like just another druid
ranger class but oh boy do things get
silly fast in the best possible way this
character is great for beginners and
anyone who just wants to have fun
the companion is tanky which gives you a
lot of space to try different play
styles you'll quickly be casting
cyclones and smashing through fields of
enemies turned snowman with your best
mushroom fred who also has a habit of
farting things to death the spore
warden's class feet is mushroom
companion and to be honest the sport
warden isn't really sure how to feel
about that i'm not going to sprout
anything if i pet you am i your mushroom
buddy deals poison damage which is great
for melting through armor and they'll
lunge at any enemy you ping
when it comes to action skills this
class has barrage and blizzard barrage
summons an ethereal bow that fires seven
arrows dealing ability damage on impact
arrows can be fired multiple times and
ricochet off surfaces they also take on
any gun damage buffs you might have
already going early in the game the bow
isn't that impressive at range it fires
arrows in a pretty wide spread and too
few arrows tend to hit each target it's
only effective as a finisher which a
whole new class of melee weapons are
already good at it's possible that later
in the game there are certain builds
that might be able to turn the bow into
something more like the golden gun from
destiny but the second action skill
blizzard is way more effective for most
of the game blizzard spawns three frost
cyclones that persist for quite a while
slowing and freezing enemies the
cyclones can even chase flying creatures
as a matter of fact once you get your
cyclones going and level up your
mushroom companion you can set a battle
in motion and just kind of sit back
there's so many status effects going on
that everything just kind of dies
although sometimes it can be hard to see
what's happening which is very
borderlands the passive skill chief for
sport warden is pretty straightforward
mostly increasing the damage and health
of your mushroom companion but there are
also two skills you should pay attention
to early on picking sporecloud lets your
buddy do their fart attack and then just
a bit later medicinal mushroom lets them
revive you when you go down in combat
this is great for solo players how to
build there's no one right way to do
this this is a very forgiving class i
went for a close range build and chose
the twist of fate called village idiot
which jacks up strength and increases
critical damage but more importantly
seemed to amp up stagger effects of
melee weapons then i dumped extra points
in dexterity for higher critical chance
and intelligence to make up for the
negative stats that come with village
idiot shoring up these weaknesses meant
a neutral spell cooldown rate in the
early game this made a hard-hitting
build that would freeze enemies with
cyclones tank with mushroom friend and
then finish with staggering melee blows
or critical shotgun hits this build
didn't need a lot of points and
constitution to boost health and shields
because enemies often just aggro it on
my companion that being said critical
hits are more associated with the stab
of answer so you may want to maximize a
spore warden in other ways or build a
more ranged class to take advantage of
barrage how to multi-class multiclassing
can also go in a wide number of ways and
we just sort of started touching on it
in the review build i went berserker to
boost frost damage from the warden's
already very effective cyclones or even
lets you become a human cyclone with a
berserker's action skill
the spell shot is a gun wizard who can
do wield magic and turn enemies into
skeet you can also make some big
mistakes mid-trees so this class is for
more advanced players who don't mind a
stats focused build that's because part
way through spellshot your shields stop
recharging on their own and are reliant
on you building damage stacks and firing
off spells to get them back another big
thing to note here is if you play with a
controller this class is physically
demanding because you'll be mashing
triggers and both bumpers almost every
attack all that being said a well-built
spell shot is a blast to play
the spell shots class feat is spell
weaving which means casting spells or
reloading weapons build stacks of
increased spell damage understanding how
spell weaving works becomes pretty vital
as you go along the spell shot's action
skills are used to either place one
particularly badass enemy on timeout or
find powerful combinations of magic
spells to melt enemies before they can
fight back unlike other classes the ambi
hextrus action skill allows the
spellshot to equip two magic spells at
the same time this can be used for some
pretty rapid-fire situations the
polymorph skill lets you turn one enemy
into a skeet which is some kind of alien
sheep thing you can attack them while
they're transfigured but if you don't
they'll become normal again after some
time if you cast polymorph on an enemy
that's too high level to transform
you'll just cast another one of your
equipped spells the spell shot passive
skills all focus on casting and
reloading weapons more quickly while
escalating your damage output through
spell weaving stacks if you like to
maximize damage through stats and aren't
too worried about unlocking flashy new
abilities then this is probably your jam
if you're a newer player or just
experimenting do not select glass cannon
mid tree that boosts spell damage but
stops your shields from recharging
automatically again make sure you fully
understand spell waving stacks or skip
the skill for now because you will die a
lot when it comes to building a spell
shot i thought it sounded like fun to
fire spells as fast as possible and
cover wide areas of the field in
elemental damage you may want to focus
on more powerful spells fired less often
for the fastest rate of spellcasting
under twist of fate i went the failed
monk route to boost intelligence and
wisdom which reduces spell cooldown and
increases elemental damage at the cost
of critical hits i then spent most of
the first part of the game dumping
points into intelligence until i could
fire off spells with the smallest
possible time in between the only
negative i noticed to this build was my
melee attacks seem to be pretty weak
multi-classing the spell shot depends on
what you want to accomplish i tend to
like to do things that just feel fun but
many of you will be more focused on
maximizing your stats consider two ideas
with a ranged offensive focus glass
cannon build for a more powerful
defensive build that lets you get a lot
closer for a ranged offensive spell shot
combine them with clawbringer mostly for
the wyvern companion that can reach out
and set things on fire but also because
if you're playing with other people this
class hands out elemental team buffs as
a matter of fact a glass cannon build
behind a few friends can be insanely
powerful a great defensive spell shot
can combine their abilities with spore
warden to get a tanky mushroom buddy
that gives you space to step back and
use them sticks at a more casual pace
there's really no right answer i didn't
try this but if you go stab them answer
you can probably vastly improve your
critical damage our reviewer even
suggested going all in on the glass
cannon build by combining them with the
grave born which sounds very risky
everything you need to know about the
berserker comes from the word play that
makes up its name it is at its heart a
riff on the berserker borderlands
version of the heavy tank class with a
twist of frost focus magic one of
wonderland's new features is the
dedicated melee weapon and if you're
interested in using it often the
berserker is the perfect fit for you
combine that with the enraged mechanic
to deal bonus frost damage and you have
a powerful close range fighter that's
all about jumping into the middle of the
action if you like having a large health
pool telling your enemies to chill
and close range weapons the berserker is
for you the berserker's class feat is
rage of the ancients which activates
enraged every time you use an action
skill what does in rage do it adds bonus
frost damage to all of your attacks the
duration of base enraged lasts 15
seconds however it doesn't deplete while
an action skill is active
so if you use dreadwin which lasts 6
seconds enraged will proc at the start
giving you a total of 21 seconds you can
also increase the duration of enraged by
35
if you activate an action skill
something you can take advantage of with
feral surge your starting action skill
is dreadwind where your fatemaker will
spin around for 6 seconds dealing damage
based on the stats of their equipped
melee weapon while in effect you have
increased movement speed and immunity to
the slow status effect so you can keep
up as enemies move around and still hit
them you may notice at the start of the
game dreadwind doesn't seem all that
effective damage doesn't hit as hard as
you'd like and enemies can still attack
you and getting put into save your soul
state ends your dread wind because
drenwin is tied to the damage of your
equipped melee weapon this is a skill
that only gets better the further into
your playthrough and you want to
prioritize passive skills that boost
melee and close range damage as well as
scavenging vending machines for better
melee weapons your second skill is feral
surge a single used lunge attack that
will deal area frost damage to enemies
feral surge is a great way to get into a
group of enemies faces quickly apply
frost damage to them and then follow up
with a close range weapon like a shotgun
however the real fun comes with the fact
that you can chain feral surge as its
cooldown will reset if you kill an enemy
with it in fact feral surge will
instantly kill an enemy if their health
is below 20 percent which is pretty easy
to tell thanks to the game's segmented
health bars
if you play this right you can keep
chaining feral surge over and over
bypassing its 32 second cooldown this
pairs beautifully with enraged which as
previously mentioned can have its
duration prolonged every time you
activate a skill to truly take advantage
of feral surge requires more thought and
planning than dreadwind but if that sort
of ability chaining excites you this is
a really cool skill as you might have
guessed the berserker's passive skills
are all about increasing the power of
frost and melee damage boosting stats
like enraged and improving the health
and damage reduction so you can stay up
close and personal so the core of an
effective berserker is strong melee
damage plenty of health to keep you
alive and using your action skills as
much as possible that means allocating
points into strength constitution and
attunement for your twist of fate
village idiot is perfect for giving you
that raw damage output up front while
keeping everything else you need neutral
recovering inventory hoarder is also a
potential option as it gives you an
extra skill cool down boost but you are
going to be sacrificing some max hp and
you'll want to put your extra points
into that to even things out when it
comes to multi-classing if you decide
you want to pair berserker with another
class's action skill pick one that has a
skill you can use frequently so you're
still activating enraged all the time
for example spore warden is a great
option with barrage which can be fired
multiple times
or you could take advantage of blizzard
and use your passive frost boost to
increase the power of these cyclones
further and as mentioned the cyclones
last for a really long time and as long
as the skill is active in rage's
duration counter doesn't go down
the clawbringer is an elemental
powerhouse and perhaps the most
well-rounded of the classes with a
fistful of fire in one hand and
lightning in the other clawbringer can
bring a little bit of everything to the
table including their trusty wyvern
companion there aren't really any tricks
to clawbringer which might make it a bit
dull if you're looking to be a little
more weird or active with your class
however if you rather focus on shooting
and letting elemental damage just happen
around you with no extra effort on your
part the claw burner is a good choice
and can be a great class to pick second
and pair with any of the others the
clawbringer's class feet is wyvern
companion a cute little flying companion
that will claw out your enemy's eyes and
rain hellfire down on them any increase
to your damage also increases your
companion's damage which makes boosting
fire damage very important if you want
your wyvern to be as effective as
possible the wyverns pretty good about
just doing their own thing and as a
result it can be pretty easy to forget
they are even there if you want a feat
that feels more active than passive you
might not like the wyvern but if you
rather have a buddy that deals bonus
damage with no effort on your part
wyvern is a good choice your starting
action skill is cleansing planes a
massive hammer strike that slams the
earth or nearby enemy skulls with large
melee damage as well as a fire nova
creating a fire area of effect attack
even at the start cleansing flame is a
powerful skill and can deal some heavy
damage making it really fun and
satisfying right out of the gate
the second action skill is storm
dragon's judgment which gives the fate
maker essentially thor's hammer it's a
range skill that you throw dealing area
of effect lightning damage for 8 seconds
wherever it lands you can also recall it
back early refunding some cooldown and
yes any enemies in its path back to you
do take damage when it comes to passive
skills the clawbringer's focus is on its
three core attributes fire damage
lightning damage and their wyvern
companion rather than splitting your
points into both fire and lightning
you're better off picking one element
and focusing on it to maximize its
potential fire might seem like the
better choice because your wyvern breeze
fire however there are passive skills
that can give your wyvern lightning
damage so really it's about picking the
element based on which action skill you
prefer and which action skill you end up
picking also is going to affect how you
build your character to some degree
which is a bit of a bummer in the early
game because you do have to pick your
skill first however you can respect and
bright hoof if you change your mind
later while not quite as melee heavy as
the berserker is melee and critical
damage still play a key role in the
clobbering's action skills and as such
strength is good to invest in the class
can be quite tanky not with hp but it's
ward thanks to a few passive skills so
constitution is another place to put
points especially if you use cleansing
flame which requires you to get up close
and personal wisdom is a great option if
you want to go all in on the elemental
side of them for twist of fate you can
pick village idiot if you want to go big
on melee and crit damage or for a
slightly more risky option rogue
alchemist gives you a large boost to
status damage at the cost of
constitution this can work out well
though if you favor long range weapons
and storm dragon's judgment
when it comes to multi-classing because
of how straightforward clawbringer is
and because most of its skills don't
require extra work to activate it can
make a great second class option it's
always nice to have more elemental
damage on your attacks and pretty much
any class can benefit from having a
wyvern following you around setting
stuff on fire i found it to be a solid
pair up with the berserker who i played
as my main class i would focus on
chaining feral surge and enraged why my
wyvern would just mop up everyone else
all right y'all i'm david and i'm here
to talk to you about the grave born or
as i like to call him a demon in a
prayer now the grave warden is an
interesting class that might not be the
most attractive on paper but damn if it
isn't effective siphoning away enemy
health through dark energy is the bread
and butter of the grave horn and it's
easier said than done the key though go
all out fully sending your character
into the heat of battle barely keeping
the balance between sacrificing your
health or regaining it back is the most
effective and fun way to play graveborn
oh and you get to do it with a kind of
cute kind of creepy demon friend along
the way sweet right so in my mind the
gravemorn is an excellent class for risk
takers players who don't really want a
class that's fully reliant on the at
range spell casting cooldowns like the
spell shot but they're not interested in
the melee brawl like the berserker
either so you'd think that the graveborn
is kind of this like perfect middle
ground for an average player that wants
the best of both worlds right but the
reality is it's probably better suited
for veterans who aren't worried about a
whittling health bar and can reliably
break themselves out of a death saver
too in the heat of the battle if they go
down so let's break down the grave
borne's abilities starting with the
class feet the demi lich companion
this floating companion will follow you
around and hit enemies at range with
dark magic which is a new element in the
game by the way that leeches enemies
health and gives it back to you whenever
you cast a spell your demi lich will
cast a hellish blast which chases down
enemies and hits them with an area
attack using the same element that you
just used early on the demi lich is
mostly just good for cracking occasional
jokes but eventually you can stack
certain upgrades to improve its efficacy
some skills will even grant you more
companions with specific perks
increasing your own damage output based
on how many companions you've got with
you at any given time kind of messed up
but you can even use your demi lich as
bait or damage that would normally go to
you becomes redirected to your
companion's health bar instead every
class has two main action skills in the
grave born we start out with dire
sacrifice
if you find the grave mourn to be kind
of barren drive so far with its
abilities dire sacrifice is the one
action skill that looks pretty rad the
way that it works is you sacrifice some
health to deal dark magic damage but you
also steal health from all enemies
nearby the more health that you
sacrifice the more bonus damage the
skill is perfect for when you are
surrounded by lots of small enemies or
you have a large boss down to a sliver
of health and want to go in for the kill
conversely if you want a strong opening
attack you can use it as a primer and
then combine certain spells or even
leeching weapons to quickly regain any
health that you had lost the second
action skill is reaper of bones reaper
of bones is basically a game of
extending the activation timer for as
long as you can when this action skill
is cast you get an increasing bonus dark
magic damage which can heal you and
extend the duration of this attack as
long as you keep getting kills the catch
is you are constantly losing health with
seemingly no end when you run out of
health you become invulnerable for a
couple of seconds and then you come back
with a small amount of health if the
timer runs out and enemies are still
alive by the time you've run out of
health then gg my friend because you are
most likely going down combining this
with health stealing magic and guns is a
must in case you deal with enemies that
were unexpectedly tankier than your
usual skeleton archer the grave horns
also got a nice set of passive skills so
the passive skill tree mostly focuses on
leeching more health and outputting more
damage to keep you alive in those full
send moments there are some fun things
that you can unlock later down the tree
such as one particular skill that has a
chance to summon a dark hydra but the
majority of your upgrade points will be
invested into maximizing your dark magic
life stealing reducing your cooldowns or
increasing the damage output of your
companions so you decided to go
graveborn perfect great choice now let's
talk about the graveborn builds when you
choose your class you can pick an origin
story that gives you certain buffs and
debuffs to particular attributes
graveborn players should go with the
failed monk origin story which depletes
your starting strength and dexterity but
dramatically improves upon intelligence
and wisdom in terms of upgrade paths a
specific skill that you should look into
early on is the faithful thralls perk
which buffs your damage based on how
many active companions you have fighting
on your behalf most of the skills are
under the hood improvements that can
activate on kills or are passively
active in the background graveborn's
usefulness overall though is heightened
by your companions so prioritizing those
that spawn more companions on your side
are a must you'll also want to consider
which action skill that you prefer do
you gamble on the reaper of bones if so
definitely put on a health leeching
loadout i cannot stress this enough this
means focusing on weapons spells and any
gear that gives you more efficient
health regeneration this can apply to
dire sacrifice as well although there's
more room to venture out and experiment
with different elemental weapons but i
would not recommend completely
abandoning health leaching weapons or
gear from your arsenal later on in the
story you will have the option to create
multi-classes that means combining two
different classes together to create
this like awesome frankenstein fusion of
the two so you might be wondering what
second class would pair well with
graveborn well combining graveborn with
spore warden creates the
horticulturalist multi-class and the two
in my opinion work together beautifully
after all the more companions that
graveborn has the better because they're
constantly causing chaos distracting
enemies and ideally leeching health back
to you this makes spore warden an
excellent choice since it comes with a
little mushroom companion right off the
bat if i found that the action skills of
reaper of bones or diary sacrifice were
too risky especially in more difficult
situations swapping the spore warden's
barrage attack of bows was a nice change
of pace but primarily it's the mushroom
buddy that does the heavy lifting you
might be tempted to try stabilmanster as
the secondary class to combine with the
graveborn which is fine but it's
important to consider the main stats
that go into each class remember that
failed monk origin story stablemanster
tends to benefit from greater dexterity
and even strain which are not the main
focus of grave1
graveborn players are better off
leveling up constitution wisdom and even
intelligence for faster spell casting
cooldowns which may combine nicely with
spellshot if you decide that spore
warden isn't your forte
alright moving on to the stabbomancer
the stab em answer is the first class
that appears when you see the class menu
and that is no coincidence it is the de
facto solo or starter class and great
for beginners or people who haven't
played borderlands in a long time
built to deal frequent bonus damage
playing as a stab-o-mancer can almost
feel like taking a co-op partner with
you early skill unlocks focus on melee
attacks movement speed buffs and
amplified critical hit damage
collectively that gives the wonderland
stablemancer a swift and deadly skill
set that makes dungeon crawling on your
lonesome more manageable than with other
classes the stablemancer's class feed is
dirty fighting which gives the class a
higher critical hit chance than the rest
that's something that can quickly be
improved upon thanks to some crit buffs
available at the base of the skill tree
like other classes the stablemancer's
two starting action skills are built
with different situations in mind using
ghostblade the stablemancer will unleash
a massive spinning blade made of magic i
guess that does several seconds of area
of effect damage at a rate determined by
their equipped melee weapon if you'd
rather get sneaky than stabby you should
consider the stab manser's other action
skill from the shadows with this the
staba manser will go invisible for a few
seconds during which time all damage you
deal counts as a critical hit though a
less powerful crit than you'd have when
not in stealth
still the bonus damage plus invisibility
can be the deciding factor in
vanquishing a fierce pack of foes or
toppling a tricky boss you could even
just use it to escape a dicey situation
and get your fate maker out of harm's
way the stablemancer's passive skills
largely focus on buffing critical hit
damage critical hit chances and the
severity and longevity of status effects
when selecting your origin story which
is called the twist of fate the game's
starter builds consider whether you want
to make your strengths even stronger or
patch up weaknesses if you're playing
solo you should design a character
background that doesn't hurt your
constitution however the best preset in
this case is the failed monk which is
built mainly for magic casters
although keep in mind the failed monk
does give a slight debuff to your
dexterity so consider that with this in
mind the route that i went was to select
raised by elves which gives me above
average dexterity in this case and thus
even more crit damage at the cost of my
constitution but then patched up that
blemish by pouring my 10 freestanding
extra points back into constitution and
strength to even it out in the end this
made my already impressive critical hits
that much stronger without sacrificing
my own health pool as a solo player when
selecting my multi-class for wonderlands
i was a few hours into the game and
feeling like my gameplay wasn't
distinctive enough from just another
borderlands i was promised fantasy but
the weapons tended to feel like
borderlands guns in a witch's hat so to
speak
so i went with something that would give
me a new perspective on the game's
combat spellshot while my build wasn't
yet suited for becoming a part-time
conjurer i started pouring hero points
into intelligence which increased my
spell cooldowns giving me more chances
to fling magic around the battlefield
for me this made a world of difference
no longer was i just swapping among a
sea of guns that didn't really feel at
home in a fantasy game suddenly with
multi-classing i was firing critical
hits from one hand and well literal fire
from the other if you're a tried and
true borderlands fan looking to mix it
up in the spin-off adding some magic to
your repertoire makes for a well-rounded
but still quite literally sharp fate
maker
and that should get you started remember
these are just some of our suggestions
from our review build of the game you'll
probably have your own favorites so let
us know what insane builds you intend to
make and what mistakes you made along
the way make sure to check out our full
review of tiny hina's wonderlands over
on gamestop's youtube channel thanks for
watching
you may be
pungent but there's no one i'd rather
have at my side